good afternoon
today small and medium-sized enterprises
can apply for european funds to protect
and make better use of
intellectual property rights the
commission and the european union
intellectual property office
created the so-called
for business sme fund to help firms
develop intellectual property strategies
and protect their ip rights both
at national and eu level 20 million
euros are available
for the first year the new grand scheme
offers financial support in the form of
reimbursements
for trademark and design registration
and
ipscan services including intellectual
property
pre-diagnostic you'll find more
information
on the scheme and a link to the
application form
in our daily news thank you
thank you very thank you very much sonia
we now move over to
balash who is here will come on the
podium
who has good news on our efforts to
increase rescue stockpiles across the
union
indeed good afternoon so the expansion
of the
rescue medical stockpile continues with
the involvement of four
member states as of today belgium the
netherlands and slovenia will become
the new host countries for rescue
medical
supplies in addition a second medical
reserve
will be established by germany which is
already
a rescue host country now in total
we have nine countries hosting the
common european stockpile
supplies have grown significantly in the
meantime and now
include more than 65 million medical
masks
and 15 million ffp2 and ffb3 masks
more than million pairs of medical
gloves
close to 20 million medical guns and
aprons
and we also have now several thousand
oxygen concentrators
and ventilators thank you very much
balash and finally
we have vivian for a last announcement
on our work to process preserve
biodiversity
vivian uh
vivian seems to have a connection
problem so i will make the announcement
myself is she there
vivian you have the floor
see me yes we do okay you do okay
so um the president of the republic of
cyprus mentioned in an interview that he
gave a newspaper
in cyprus this weekend that he intends
to negotiate
and um get some kind of
um uh coveted vaccine i don't know which
type
from israel and not from the eu and not
from the uh
from the existing uh agreement that
there is
first of all can he do that is it even
possible to negotiate with a third
country
and get uh any type of vaccine from that
third country
in addition to what uh the eu is
providing
and he also mentioned some very specific
accusations for delays he accused the eu
for delays specifically in regard to the
uh
deployment of vaccines in cyprus are you
aware of any cyber specific delays of
that kind
so those are my two questions thanks
thank you very much i passed the floor
to
thank you very much for this question um
first of course we will not give any
comments on on comments or
or or step into speculation as far as
this issue is concerned i think
uh and as far as the nature of such
announcements are concerned i think it's
best to check with
the separate authorities um what they
have in mind here i think what is very
important for us
is that the negotiations and the
conclusion of contracts take place
within the political and legal framework
of our vaccine strategy
as has been stressed last week by the
president
and we also had the opportunity to
discuss this a little bit more in detail
in last week's midday press briefing so
first this is
the framework which applies to the
negotiation and conclusion
of contracts with our portfolio of
vaccine developers on the separate
specificities
regarding the the fastness or not
fastness of the role of vaccines of
course we do not have
any comments you know that the european
commission has already issued in
mid-october a recommendation
to help member states with the
preparation of this
vaccine campaigns member states are
working on this
we are offering support where member
states believe that such support may be
useful
but this is of course as eric has also
expressed a few times already last week
an enormous an enormous challenge
and we all have to set our minds to it
and
make sure that we can have this roll out
of the vaccines as quickly as possible
thank you i see you have a follow-up
yeah
should we presume from what we have just
heard
that they did not contact you for this
israel
vaccine deal thanks but atanasius
we why would why should we be
aware necessarily of um of such contacts
um remember that the european union
is um responsible for negotiating with
the
um with the pharmaceutical companies
that were
identified as having interesting
candidates
for a vaccine we have not taken over
uh the whole of the um
of the vaccination efforts of member
states i'm not
aware of these contacts between or
potential contacts between
uh cyprus and israel but if there are
discussions between
cyprus and israel on i don't know which
vaccine
by the way this is not necessarily
something
which which is immediately of relevance
to us what is of relevance to us
obviously as we have said time and time
and time
time and time again here in the press
room is the fact that for
a vaccine to be deployed in the european
union
it needs to have been it needs to have
followed the authorization
processes that we have
so a positive assessment by uh by emma
and the market authorization by the
european union if it is
um one of the uh vaccines developed by
one of the
providers that we are negotiating with
are there other questions for us
on vaccines today
please only keep your hand raised if
your
question concerns vaccines
and i see that sandor has a question
tomorrow there will be a hearing at the
european parliament
with the commission about the
vaccination strategy and
it's pretty sure that meps will want to
have a bigger transparency
in terms of they will want to know the
the
timeline of the rollout of the vaccines
and also maybe they will demand
more details on their liability issues
in the contract so my question is
why are these two issues
secret and is there any willingness from
the commission's side to
you know be more transparent
thank you sir no let's let's be clear
the commission has always said that it
wants to be
as transparent as possible in
the framework that is the one under
which we have been
negotiating the contracts with the
vaccine and vaccine developers with the
pharmaceutical
companies and we are working on
on this and of course hope to make
progress on this
and if there are developments in this
regard we will
make announcements as soon as possible
jack question on vaccines
oh sorry it's not on vaccines i
understand sorry
um please only keep your hand raised if
it is
on vaccines thank you martin
thank you yeah going back to the issue
of getting vaccines from
from third countries since other eu
member states might get the same idea
could you just clarify
can they actually buy vaccines from
third countries
without breaking this principle of
solidarity which is also legally binding
as you inform us last year
thank you look this is a completely
hypothetical question
um honestly what we have said we have a
framework in place as stefan has
explained time and time again
which concerns our negotiations with the
pharmaceutical
companies for advanced purchasing
agreements
this is what this is what our
our process refers to now
we would really need to have more
details on what
type of third country contacts
are mentioned here in order to be able
to comment and since we don't have
these details as far as i'm aware it's
very difficult for us to comment here
on the on the podium what i can what i
can say
since this issue continues to come is
that
the president has asked commissioner key
yakidas
to send a letter to all health ministers
asking them to provide us with all the
necessary transparency
on the way in which they are complying
with the provisions of our vaccine
strategy
in terms of contacts or lack of contacts
rather
with with those pharmaceutical companies
that we have been or are negotiating
with so this letter is currently being
drafted
and will be sent as soon as it is ready
do we have other questions on vaccines
today i see one hand raised jerome
yes thank you very much eric um
just on the issue of vaccines you know
in some countries i mean for example in
ireland it was reported that
up to 40 000 vaccines were sitting in
dublin
for more than two weeks and you know
when
this issue has been highlighted on some
of the flagship news programs the
current affairs programs there seems to
be
sort of very little scrutiny in terms of
what has been happening at eu level for
example i understand that the european
commission
published its vaccine strategy in june
and then
on the 15th of october it published a
rollout strategy
um and you know but from what i'm
hearing is
this this issue is not being raised to
government ministers and so my question
is about communication is there a
communication deficit from the european
commission point of view
you obviously have yourself and stefan
and commissioner kariakis and
president vonderlein excellent
communicators in various languages
but i've never heard any of you on just
as one example
being interviewed one-on-one situation
on the media in ireland which i could
imagine would be very effective in terms
of getting the eu's message across
and i don't say this is a criticism per
se i mean it's been it's been suggested
that brexit
might not have happened if the eu was
better able to communicate its
achievements
but actually this is a bigger issue
because this is an issue of life and
death
and so if government ministers and civil
servants are being left let off the hook
because they're not being asked the
right questions or the european
commission isn't conveying
its policies clearly enough people are
not getting the jabs
and therefore it is a matter of life and
death so is there i mean i've been
listening to
i only got back i was listening to all
the debates here on vaccines
over the last couple of weeks that went
on for ages and very good questions very
good answers but it
seems to me it strikes me a little bit
like an echo chamber because i didn't
hear any of this
on the media in ireland just ireland as
an example but from speaking to
colleagues i hear the same
is happening in other countries so is
there a communications deficit
is there is there a problem really about
the strategy in terms of communication
jerome we have been communicating
through all channels possible when it
comes
to the procurement
policy that we have put in place in
order to purchase
vaccines and on the
importance for member states to define
and roll out effective vaccination
strategies and it must be however very
clear that
the vaccination strategies are the
responsibility of member states
who have the opportunity of exchanging
best practices exchanging information
among themselves in the health security
committee estefan has highlighted here
a certain number of times we have
ourselves
made sure that we could provide advice
whenever asked
on what we see as a priorities when it
comes to vaccination groups
but the fact is vaccination strategies
are ruled out
by member states and on the point
uh the specific point that you were
making
related to vaccines and they're being
used or not being used
let me remind you that we have signed
the advanced purchasing agreements
but then the member states um
sign the specific purchase orders
purchase forms
that allow them therefore to calibrate
within the framework of these advanced
purchasing agreements
the deliveries of vaccines according to
their needs
basically according to their vaccination
strategies so this means that we are
trying
to ensure that each of the responsible
players
is playing the role that corresponds to
their responsibilities
jerome you still have your hand right do
you have a follow-up
thanks just one quick follow-up then let
me uh without the sort of ranty element
of it let me be more specific about the
question
i hope i have my dates right but the the
vaccine rollout strategy was
was unveiled by the european commission
on the 15th of october i think
i'm pretty sure it's the 15th of it was
mid-october anyway
so my question is if
each of the 27 member states had of
taken that vaccine
strategy rollout and implemented as it
was written down on the paper
regardless of whether they have the
vaccine to not obviously wants to get
the vaccines but in terms of if they
have implemented
this vaccine rollout is it the european
commission's view
that there wouldn't be any problems in
terms of the distribution of the vaccine
in member states
joe i'm going to pass the floor to staff
on details but i think that
the the the commission has
not issued a detailed
uh specific document specifying to each
member state
in great detail what it is that uh
how exactly they should be rolling out
their vaccination strategy
um for a very simple reason member
states are extremely different
um in in size in population number
um in in institutional framework
when it comes to the organization of the
health services
et cetera et cetera and therefore what
we have done as the president reminded
us here
on on friday last friday is we have
explained a certain number of principles
and key priorities
in particular when it comes to the
priority groups that should be getting
the vaccine but then of course
it is up to each member state to
organize the vaccination process
but i pass the floor now to stefan more
specifically on the documents that we
have issued
and what they say and do not what they
say
thank you very much eric now you're
absolutely right again as you said in
the beginning there
our the vaccination policies are
national competence now of course
it was very important for the commission
to make sure that these vaccinations
have been a coordinated way that's in
the interests of the member states in
the interest
of the european union as a whole which
is why on the 15th of october
you write your own the recommendation
date from the 15th of october
we adopted this recommendation where we
invite the member states to reflect on
on a series of very important elements
something they need to do to prepare
their vaccination campaigns
we invite member states for instance to
reflect on the identification of the
priority groups
who should be vaccinated first and we
suggest
a list of um groups that we believe
should be considered to reflect on this
prioritization exercise
we invite the members to reflect on
making sure that the necessary
infrastructure is in place
that necessary equipment is in place
taking into account
the technical specificities of the
vaccines as you know each
vaccine comes with its own specificities
and its own logistical challenges
we invite member states to reflect on
the necessary staff in making sure that
you have enough staffing
skilled staffing we invite member states
to also reflect on
organizing the necessary communication
so that
the european citizens are well informed
about the vaccination campaign
and so these recommendations have all
been made to help the member states to
actually
prepare these vaccination campaigns but
then indeed it's up to the member states
to take this exercise forward and to
translate this
into actual plans and implemented
vaccinations thank you
and stefan is too modest to say this but
if i remember well he was actually on
irish television
last week specifically on our vaccine
strategy so we have been present
somewhat at least on
irish media right i see no further
questions
on um vaccines per se but i know that
louise
had a question on a coronavirus related
issue
on the danish travel rules so let us
continue
with louise louise you have the floor
thank you eric thank you for the
question yeah i wanted to ask you about
the new danish travel rules that were
announced on friday afternoon
the danish government is now advising
against all travel abroad even for
business travelers
and it's also restricting travel into
the country so that
uh both eu citizens and even danish
citizens can now be turned away
if they fail to show a negative test
that is less than 24 hours old
so first i wanted to ask have you been
notified about these rules in advance
and what is your reaction thank you
thank you i think this uh sits somewhere
between
christian and adelbere but let's go to
christian first
yes hello good afternoon and thank you
for your question
i will i will stay more general on this
one um
not common in detail on on on individual
measures
uh taken by individual member states but
that reminds
uh that the commission has been pushing
for increased and
better coordination at eu level for
various initiatives and guidelines over
the past
months we are of course in regular
contact with all member states and we
are closely
monitoring the situation um
physical distancing and self-discipline
continues to be necessary in the
current circumstances and of course
until the vaccination is more
widely available as you know the ectc
recommends that people should be
encouraged to reduce
activities associated with increased
transmission such as travel and social
activities
at the same time citizens understandably
expect member
states to further step up coordination
efforts
regarding free movement and to ensure of
course timely
information on new health and travel
measures
you can on individual measures of course
they would invite you to check also our
reopen
eu platforms which contains the latest
information
on coronaries measures received by us
from the member states so we make them
available
directly there
let me mention maybe two p two uh
recommendations that we have put out
uh still the one uh of course from the
13th of october
where member states have committed to
ensure more coordination and
better information on this one we need
to see
more progress on implementing these
commitments and
recall on member states to further
work on this and step up their efforts
and i would like to remind also on the
on the commission recommendation that we
put out in the context of
the uk variant variant of the virus
just ahead of christmas which also
contains
recommendations specifically for this
new situation and basically you can
we put out a press release back then but
basically
it was it was recommending to to limit
all
non-essential travel as much as possible
but at the same time
keep possible essential
treble and of course
free movement of essential workers
transport workers etc
thank you and on
whether the the danish authorities have
notified
these measures are not i passed the
floor to adelbere
yes perhaps just to add that indeed we
are aware of the fact that
border internal border controls are in
enforce in
denmark that we have a notification
from the danish authorities in place for
controls at internal borders from the
12th of november 2020 all the way up to
the 11th of may
2021
thank you luis you have a follow-up
yes thanks so much i don't want to thank
you for the answers i just wanted to ask
christian so do you think this is a good
example of
coordination efforts and that then
denmark is following
sort of the rules and the spirit of
those quotes you mentioned
and also do you worry that other
countries might follow that this could
set off a new spiral of
restrictions and closures thank you
christian
well as a and as i said at the very
beginning um i'm going to
not comment in in detail or or make a
value judgment of of
individual measures you can find these
measures
uh as far as i'm aware already on our
reopen eu
platform and what i would like to repeat
in general is that it is very important
for member states
to coordinate and to inform
in time and in advance of any new
measures and any changes in the measures
that they're taking
thank you okay are there any other
questions
for us on the um health uh
on the pandemic situation in uh
europe please only keep your hand raised
if it is
the case thomas is your question on this
is your question on this yes it is and i
hope
you can hear me yes um i was wondering
and i've asked also asked this question
by email i was wondering
um which commissioners have been in
current time
the last couple of weeks since the
christmas break
and a lot of them have been in their
home countries
um thank you very much for that for that
question
what is what is clear is that
as you know all commissioners
are required to comply with the uh with
the rules
that are in place in belgium obviously
without
prejudice to their privileges
under the privileges and immunities
agreement that we have
with belgium but they are supposed to
respect
the rules that are in place in in
belgium which means that fundamentally
they can come
and to work for um essential meetings
but in their private lives they have to
they have to comply with these with
these rules
and now we do not keep a roster
of exactly which commissioner is
where at which point in time when they
have come back etc
and since this is private information it
is up to each commissioner
to ensure that they respect the rules
you have a follow-up
of course private information but some
of these commissioners
are willingly enough to share this
private information on on
social media websites and there we can
see that
uh for example commissioner kiriakides
have been
in has been in cyprus for for several
several days i think more than a week
she's not the only one so it's unfair to
just mention her the same is true i
think for commissioner soyka
for commissioner lena
um so i'm still wondering
have these people been when they came
back to belgium
uh have they been in in current time and
did they do a test on the first and the
seventh day
well as i say i said i can only repeat
what i've just said which is that it is
their responsibility to ensure
that they comply with the with the
belgian rules
all right um let us now move on to
other issues and therefore i go back to
jack
you had a question on the suspension
of president trump
i understand from social media correct
yeah hi eric i have two questions
actually i have
i want to ask about uh the president's
call with uh uh
president erdogan over the weekend as
well but i know that there are other
questions on this
so my thing we all read the the thierry
breton
the commissioner breton um thing about
suspending the social media accounts and
in that op-ed
in politico he mentioned sort of
coordination
with u.s uh forced u.s
regulators etcetera to deal with this i
wonder
um if you can clarify whether the
commission
as part of this is saying that um
that there should they should be
considered to be publishers like
like us um and also what kind of
coordination
would work with u.s regulators in
dealing with social media platforms and
how they operate
under the dsa thank you
question for johannes
thank you eric hi jack
let me first say that we have of course
seen the reports on the decision
of social media platforms to suspend the
accounts of the president of the united
states
this is primarily the responsibility of
the platforms
enforcing down terms of services
now on your question on the op-ed i mean
it's out there so i
would not like to comment on what the
commissioner says in his op-ed
um i think we have put forward as you
know
in the middle of december 50th of
december the dsa in the dma proposal
then of course
this is for the european union and
on the other hand the aim is of course
that these rules once adopted may also
inspire
governance at a more global level at
this stage i cannot now
preempt what would be out the outcome of
these discussions and how then a more
global coordination could work i mean
this is uh
let's say two steps ahead um but i think
this is what the commission wanted to
hinder
that um the rules that we would like to
introduce for the european union
which balance basically the respect for
on the one hand
accountability of pla solid respect for
the fundamental rights and the freedom
of speech with
more accountability of the platforms
that this may also inspire
a cooperation at global level
jack you have a follow-up question on
this question on this yeah so
so i suppose my question is is what the
commissioner wrote in that political
op-ed
is that the european commission's
position on the suspension of accounts
on social media now can we take that to
be neither commission's position
jack as you know very well the
commission's position is determined by
the decisions
of the college and but obviously
commissioners
in the run-up to decisions have the
possibility of expressing
what they think should be a good policy
line
and i think this is exactly what the
commissioner
has done so this is feeding into a
debate
i know that there was another question
on the same
issue from um mauro
oh angela sorry angela apologies
can you hear me yes apologies sorry
thank you don't worry
i i'm used to it also in italy uh
yes on the same on the same topic um
i was wondering in reading the what
berton said
to politico how would you how do you
fit the digital services act
which says that what is illegal offline
should
be also illegal online
with the criticism exercised
by breton on the decision by twitter to
suspend
trump's account i mean
trump made maybe an illegal act
to call for the protests at capitol hill
hill
and everything we all know and twitter
decided
okay you can't say that because that is
illegal you can't say that on twitter
so how do you reconcile the the
dsa with the criticism of
the twitter twitter's decision
thank you
um thank you angela i think the um
let me say so if you look at your op-ed
um
the phrase you kind of now uh used to
illustrate it was why we reported is
certainly i would say put out of context
but within a wider context in this
context he says
it is uh it we have to put a question
mark there and the fact that the ceo can
basically take a decision to take down
an account but the more fundamental
question
this is what is and it's written for the
more fundamental question is
why did it come so far and why did
platforms not act before
against incitement or hate but against
this information against
hate speech online and and this is the
point he's making so why do we come to
this point
and this is exactly what it is i would
like to give an answer for the european
union
that you would like to reconcile the
respect for the fundamental
rights and i'm happy to explain to you
how we would like to do that
together with with more accountability
of the platforms who have to inform
or under these proposals would need to
inform about
the way they moderate content would need
to to set out in clear terms what are
the rules
and would need to inform about a
decision for example to spend an account
but then
the user could also seek address um so
there's
these clear steps foreseen um under ddsa
proposals so i think it's actually not a
contradiction
but an illustration of the need to have
more regulation
and at least our answer for the eu is
the ddsa in that respect
thank you very much johannes are there
other questions on this issue please
only keep your hand raised if you have a
question
on this lucas
can you hear me yes go ahead so
on the way of this decision of facebook
twitter concerning
an account of president trump the
popularity of others
alternative social network platform is
growing
and of course european commission has an
account
on twitter facebook commissioners has an
account
have an account on it so do you consider
or did you consider as a way of
diversification and maybe
some way of a promotion of the
diversification
to open uh channels of communication on
another new social networks and not to
be just dependent on your
us giants tech corporations thank you
well there's a question about corporate
um communication policy of the
commission so it's not digital
policy per se and of course it depends
also a little bit on um on the different
uh college members for example if you
hinted that but there's of course a
corporate communication as well of the
commission we're not present only on
twitter we're not present only on
facebook on the
networks that you mentioned um
we have like a quite diversified
strategy
but of course i cannot now um make any
assumptions about what the future
policy may bring of course the idea is
to reach out to a variety
of psychologists and citizens to inform
about your policies and so the idea is
to go where they are
but that's all i can say i think
david you have the floor
uh thank you eric david price your
democracy
uh yes it's it's a much larger issue
than
uh president trump being cut off from
twitter i mean it's quite extraordinary
that
a president in in office should be cut
off from uh
from communication but there are uh and
it's not just twitter it's
uh a whole lot of social media and then
it's not just a whole lot of social
media
it's a whole lot of of communicators uh
who've been cut off simultaneously so
and they're not all in violation
of the so-called community rules
some of them are presenting information
which is
not inciting violence or anything like
that but presenting information
which is contrary uh to uh some of the
uh
uh some political parties in america
and so on uh and another issues quite a
lot of other issues
uh parlor for example has been cut off
um
because uh it's being hosted on amazon
uh computers so there's a question
of cartel action here uh
as well as the
uh uh communication problem so
there's a there's a cartel action
against communication which is basically
what i
would like to say and if
is it a large second question is sorry
i'm just just putting it together but
those are the
elements the the question is are you
analyzing the cartel action of this
not in a normal economic cartel but a
communications cartel
i don't think we can answer that
question here on the on the podium
based on um very very recent
developments as you know the commission
is very much in favor of
media pluralism in general we've had the
opportunity of
depicting here in the press room many
times the actions that we
undertake in this in this respect but we
will not comment further
on this dimension
pitra a question also on this
we cannot hear you petra
your mic source must be wrong
sorry so we will whilst you try to solve
your um your mic
issue we will move on um
[Music]
and i now open the floor to
other issues and go to ego
ego you have the floor yeah hi eric do
you hear me
yes go ahead perfect uh i'm the
colleague of petra's
and we have i guess quite similar
questions
and this is regarding the financing of
slovenian press
agency uh the government actually the
government communication office last
week announced
that the financing of the
sta is a direct law obligation
and on the other hand that means that
this opens the question
whether this is a kind of a state aid or
not
and the other question would be also
is this the question of competition
that's what the
government communication office wrote so
my question would be
has the commission got any requests so
far from
the government's communication office of
slovenia
regarding uh the question of so-called
state aid
or not uh the second question would be
uh what would be your answer if you got
this
question and maybe the last question
uh do you think that this might be a
kind of
limiting of press freedom
thank you i pass the floor to ariana on
the stadium question
hi gora hi petra and hi eric i hope you
can hear me and
and see me i will leave the third
question to christian of course
on the first two questions what i can
tell you right now
is that the commission is in contact
with the slovenian authorities on this
matter
i can also add that in general stated
rules enable member states to grant aid
to press
agencies as compensation for services of
general economic interest
and that if certain conditions are met
including that the amount of aid is
below
a certain threshold compensation can be
granted
without prior notification and approval
by the commission so they can be
implemented directly
thank you christian do you have anything
to add on the third question
yes i'm happy to add a few words i mean
the commission is of course aware of the
decision
to discontinue the funding for the
slovenian press agency i think we have
already
said that when the decision was taken in
december media should be able to
work freely and independently everywhere
in the european union
this lies at the heart of media
pluralism
public media play a special role in the
european union
and we call on all member states to
refrain from attempts
on putting pressure on them we attach
great importance to those fundamental
values as expressed
in the european democracy action plan
and media audiovisual
action plan where media freedom and
pluralism are of course
core elements the decision
related to funding of the agency needs
to be scrutinized at
a national level by relevant authorities
of course
and we will continue to monitor the
situation closely
thank you christian petra
do you have another angle on these on
this story
then igor's
no no sorry your mic source is still not
not working we'll give the floor back to
igor for a follow-up
my first question did you get any
new requests from the slovenian
government in the last
days regarding the this so-called state
aid
i think that diana has told you what she
could tell you uh when she was saying
that we were
in contact i don't think that she will
go into further
detail on this petra in view of your
issues i suggest that you get in touch
bilaterally
on on this so that we can move on
so um i now go back to
jack who had a question i believe on the
vtc
with uh president erdogan
jack hi eric yeah hi eric sorry um
so uh firstly i have a question on why
um the president and why the commission
didn't release a sort of fuller
statement and
just a short tweet after what's kind of
a quite an important call i just
i'd assume and also i wonder if you can
give us an update or sort of a
clarification on
what the commission's position is
regarding turkey specifically this idea
of these
liberalization this sort of openness
what the commission
and what the member states i suppose is
a member state's question but i wonder
if you can just outline the commission's
position on
where the relationship lies between
turkey and the european union at the
moment just remind us of that thanks
thank you jack on your first question we
very often
release tweets after conversations
between the president and heads of state
or government so there was absolutely no
difference here
[Music]
in the way we have communicated after
this vtc
and many of the vtcs that the president
has had
with other heads of state or or
government
on your second question i passed the
floor to peter
thank you and good afternoon to everyone
well i mean i would jack refer you to
the council conclusions
uh the latest from december and i recall
that the eu all the eu member states
have said that uh they are interested
that we are interested in having
a constructive uh relationship with
turkey based on cooperation
and our work and efforts since not only
since the last conclusions in december
but actually
the whole last year are directed and
focused on achieving this
and you can see the the video conference
call of
uh by by president from the lion and
hrvp boreal with president erdogan
as part of the outreach by the european
union to convey these messages to
discuss
the need to the escalate and to the need
to do practical steps
in order to move us on this on this road
of constructive or renewal of
constructive cooperation and dialogue
because this is what is needed
and in this sense the eu position is not
changed it's captured in the new council
conclusions
and also this is something what the
commission and the hrvp are
uh working on in line with the tasking
from the leaders from last december so
to prepare the overall overview of our
relations
what do we want what do we want to
achieve what do we expect and what do we
have
on offer and this is continuing and as i
said all these contacts and engagements
are feeding into this process
thank you let us stick on the issue of
relations with
turkey attanasios oh sorry jack i saw
you had a follow-up perhaps but
we'll come back atanacios
yeah it's a kind of follow-up on this
so have you been notified by uh
turkey or their diplomatic services
of the uh intention of
the minister chabusuglu to officially
call greece for exploratory talks next
week
do you have that information did they
tell you did erdogan
uh notify the president during the
teleconference of that intention
or is it any is it officially
communicated to you
in any other midst thanks peter
did we get official information on this
well at this stage as far as i am ever i
i don't know anything about any official
notification but i would like to
underline one thing that uh
the normalization or the discussions
between greece and turkey and the
engagement between these two countries
is also very important part of uh of the
overall relations between the eu and
turkey because the irritants which were
uh
perceived by some of our member states
are perceived by the whole us irritants
and they need to be removed so
in this sense the the renewal or the
start of the talks is something the eu
is expecting
and something that we expect would
positively fit into the overall effort
to develop the positive track in our
relations
thank you now let's move to christian
on this issue
the president
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a
foreign
nikolai a question on this as well
yes yes uh nichole nielsen you observer
president erdogan was also spoke about
updating the eu turkey statement and i
was wondering if
president wonderlion supports this
proposal as well
thank you thank you very much i will not
nothing
to the uh to the readout the short
readout that we gave
of the of the conversation that took
place on on saturday at this stage
this was a conversation which is
taking place in a process that you know
very well that stems
from the european council of
last december and for the moment i will
leave it
at that
all right i now open the floor to any
other remaining issues you might have
for us
today are there other questions
that does not seem to be the case so
thank you very much bon appetit and see
you tomorrow